e a prendere berlino io continuo ad
esplorare poche vitale berlino dove
siete
sapevo che sarebbe finita così
[Musica]
aretha sanità dove sei e rimani no
andiamo lì esce fuori a rita mi ero
allontanato con berlino perché aveva
sentito qualcosa lì vita esce fuori dove
sei
berlino cristo dove anita e lei dentro
finora da questa forte andiamo da qui
[Musica]
eccovi finalmente aspetta che accendo la
luce non si può sapere dove è finito
struzzo mormino che cosa ti è successo
un paio di contenere raccontarti ma
prima aiutami a spiegarmi sì certo però
ho una domanda io per te adesso eri tu
che dovevi catturare la creatura con la
corda ma mi sa che la creatura allegato
a te che ak abbraccio dai andiamo al
piano di sotto e ti spiego tutto ok
andiamo in che cosa è successo
esattamente ad una mano mi ha trascinato
dentro alla stanza una mano era tutto
buio non ho visto niente
mi sono ritrovata allegata con la mia
stessa corda com'è possibile non è
sentito magari un rumore un verso
qualcosa
no non c'era assolutamente niente dove è
finito io sono corso dietro berlino
probabilmente avrà sentito qualcosa ed è
scappato
abbiamo paura lasciarlo da solo è
scappato via c'è qualcosa che non quadra
tu sei scomparso e nel momento in cui
stai scomparso sono tornati i rumori i
suoni ei passi in più io ti chiamavo ma
tu non mi sentivo non hai
sentito niente quando mi sono seduta
chili di fronte alla porta una mano
pelosa mi ha afferrato una mano pelosa
come la mia si è dato una mano per amata
come la tua
come inizio che stai cercando di farmi
un oggetto è tutto uno scherzo
organizzato da te e cosa stai dicendo
io sono andato dietro un merlino perché
probabilmente ha sentito qualcosa del
corso fuori sono andato a recuperarlo
fuori qualcosa che non quadra con le tue
sparizioni
ogni volta che tu sparisci sento i passi
anche loro li sentono ogni volta che tu
sparisci
ma secondo me ti stai sbagliando ma è
cosa riqua si storce la che cosa c'è
scritto qualcosa le le ave le ave l'inps
vuol dire va bene perchè ti sei iscritto
questa cosa qua non la scritta io non
capisci con mano che mi ha afferrato la
dentro ha scritto questo nella mia
guancia league quindi è qualcosa che
vuole che noi andiamo via da casa mostra
perché quella creatura vide ora al piano
di sopra di noi dobbiamo andarsene via
matteo sarà iscritta dove mi stai
prendendo in giro perché dovrei
scrivermi libro sulla guancia e perché
una creatura che via dalla piena
era nella mia tasca deve averlo messo la
creatura così com'è scritto questo nella
mia guancia
forse un biglietto ma cosa giustissima
ma non c'è scritto niente è un pezzo di
scatola è un indizio forse è che tipo di
indizione abbiamo forse lasciato delle
scatole al piano di sopra
l'unica scatola che abbiamo lasciato al
piano di sopra sai benissimo che scatola
è la scatola che non va aperta no non mi
dire lo scatolo dove trovavo tutte le
carte del cibo e cibo era sparito dal
mio più grande paura no fini ma il
problema vero non è buste di cibo vuote
ma le creature che uscivano perché ti
ricordi cosa fa quella scatola spero che
questo non sia un pezzo di quella
scatola ma se sono un modo per scoprirlo
dobbiamo tornare sopra e cercare la
scatola e vedere se è stata aperta o
meglio riaperta ma io non voglio tornare
là sopra dopo quello che mi è successo
per ciò che andrai tu io non c'entro io
lo dice che non mi credi che non hai
paura di niente quindi ma il tuo
recuperare la scatola ok
vai ti serve qualcosa un po di coraggio
porta alla camera potè così possiamo
riprendere se c'è qualcosa
ok dice che non hai paura solo paura
bucce vuote esatto ma tu capisci quello
si mangiano tutto il mio cibo no tav
amaro intensivo le scatolette la trovi
porterà subito qua ok ok va bene ok
andiamo a prendere questa scatola
speriamo bene
se un po di rumori qui era qui la messa
qui erano dei rumori di confezioni di
cibo ei qualcuno sta scattando le
confezioni del mio cibo
ecco la scatola guardate è proprio
questa non aprire prendiamo questa
scatola e scegliamo ei mezzi sono solo
dice un padre ma come vi faccio a cadere
così berlino si è preoccupato ma ad
essere inciampato duri e ripeti come al
solito la scatola siro trovata ma sei
sicuro che questa la scatola non c'è
scritto non aprirla sì li guarda guarda
bene dall altro lato c'è scritto l'ho
visto prima
ecco vedi è qui che questa non verdi non
aprirla non merlino meglio non aprirla e
pericoloso ma per prenderli lo vuole
aprirla quando ho sentito qualcosa
dentro vada il peso di scatola vediamo
per coincide si è brutto il motto che
cosa vorrà dire che un indizio è meglio
se proviamo ad aprirla anche se
pericoloso per vedere se funziona ancora
ok ok il cuore approvo public che
provate aprirla piano piano
[Musica]
tenta
e il male non c'è niente completamente
vuota che cosa vuol dire questo forse
vuol dire che tutte le creature dentro
sono scappati i ricordi tutte le cose
che abbiamo rinchiuso qua dentro
sì certo un sono scappato per un se
qualcuno ha aperto questa scatola vuol
dire che sono tutti in giro per casa un
nuovo queste grave questo è molto grave
tutte le mie paure del cibo sono
scappate ritorneranno sotto forma di
confezioni di cibo quote già rosicchiate
smangiucchiate da qualcun altro
ma ti sembra il momento di pensare a
omaggiare adesso e alle confezioni vuote
non capisci che sono scappati tutti
proprio tutti da questa scatola questa
volta line sentito anche tu vero sì ma
ieri è stato solo un ramo di una palma è
una giornata molto ventosa oggi invece
vi faccio vedere la porta
[Musica]
cosa dobbiamo fare adesso la scatola è
stata riaperta
c'è qualcuno che vuole che se ne andiamo
via per sempre
tu non mi credi cosa dobbiamo fare
hai sentito sembra un fruscio non voleva
la volta qui
ok senti vai tu a controllare se c'è
qualcosa po fuori ok io io perquisire o
meglio la scatola dei ragazzi ora
perquisì rola scatola speriamo di
trovare qualcosa dentro motore un
indizio un biglietto
voi vi credete vero lasciate un mi piace
qui sotto se voi vi credete verrebbe poi
ha deciso di farmi dall'assistente così
se succede qualcosa si sarà lui a
proteggermi
bene ora per cui siamo bene lo stato la
[Musica]
non c'è niente qua è completamente vuota
deve esserci qualcosa dato che sono
uscite fuori quelle creature to berlino
che ne pensi
pensi che ci sia qualcosa nascosta qua
dentro anche tu non sei convinto vero
marino va bene allora controllo meglio
dove sono finito vitale secondo te devo
lasciare perdere
va bene e ragione forse ne sto
preoccupando troppo dice che dovrei
controllare meglio mi sono scocciata che
questa storia non so più che cosa
controllare io lascio qua pecchiamo
vitale adesso ok
chi siete
io ho controllato dappertutto ma qui non
c'è niente non saprei proprio da dove
vengono questi rumori o che cosa sia una
vedi la scatola che si muove fino a
raccontarlo c'è qualcosa che non va
nella scatola nido nel frattempo andiamo
a vedere che cosa sta facendo unità
verità ma c'è qualcosa qua dentro mi da
che cosa denunciarli che cosa è successo
niente qualcosa mi ha afferrato e mi ha
portato dentro alla scatola dentro la
scatola ma se non c'è niente cosa
iscritti che cosa c'è scritto c'è
scritto no ora in inglese now
dobbiamo andarcene da qua e alla festa
[Musica]